the first rule of Fight Club is we don't
Sue each other outside of this let's say
they weren't fighting and Dylan was
doing this okay now I see defamation
he's going after your girl your fiance
that makes sense as soon as you sign the
contract to fight you make him pay with
your fist not with your lawyers not with
your money through your fist that's why
you're fighting now all your the Logan
Paul fans can't stand Dylan for doing
this now you get to watch the guy that
you love punch the other guy in the face
dim the rules that's how this goes
Nobody wins when you sue nobody a judge
might say this guy wins you both lose
when parents get divorced they bring in
lawyers everybody loses mom loses dad
loses the kids definitely lose I don't
like that they're going down this road
in any facet all I'm saying is I
sympathize with Dylan if I'm going to
sell a fight I can't go based off his
fighting credentials so what else are we
going to do to sell this thing what else
are we going to